are you looking through your DMS at all
I do look through my checkmark it was
like a top request that'll that'll weed
em out because I just go disco
blue check blue check look there's
something about a blue check that just
makes you like oh this person serious
doesn't have an STD it is scary like how
much like a blue check does like it's
like really shitty to say but it's like
it's everything that was my move Tyler
that was my big goal is get a [ __ ]
little check check because I think it
would change everything with girls girls
really care about it you makes you stand
out because like it's say I were to like
ask a guy out or like try to like get
into a guy's like getting a guy's
attention in his team's and he's like
has a million followers they're not
gonna see you right but if you have that
little blue it's like our eyes are like
woah like you I can go like be going so
fast on a roll and I see a blue passed
by yeah
I had girlfriends in LA when I moved
here and they would call they would call
people to check barks that day they
would go oh you're getting that verified
dick and like that was that was like
their way of referring to people with
blue checkmark yeah so
[Music]